um we talked about earlier you and drago
talking about doing a joint project you
and blast have a joint project if
there's another artist out there
that you could do a joint project with
or maybe you might be working on one
with i don't know who would that be
doug
that would be crazy it should be od
i hope he gets out man through bro
yeah it's rough it is rough
you know
not to get dive too much into this thing
but the the best part about the the the
silver lining is that it was uh
the georgia state police rico it wasn't
a federal rico at least not yet
so it's
it wasn't like it was the [ __ ] fbi it
was the georgia exactly it was a georgia
rico so you know and i can only assume
that georgia don't have their [ __ ]
together all the time because it is a
[ __ ] incompetent state so and i just
i just know that's a good dude you know
what i'm saying i mean we talking about
it
[ __ ] hit me i mean every other day i
love you bro you're good you feel me are
you feeling like just off gp like he
just
i just know slime from being like as
solid as they come
so i hate to see him in that situation
for sure
yeah we just had snap dog on the show
and he said that he was like hanging out
with with doug for like a year straight
and he was like
he noticed doug noticed he always would
have these glasses on
and because his vision is [ __ ] up
and he said that doug just randomly hit
him and say hey you got an appointment
at the doctor tomorrow to go get your
eyes done and he paid for it
like that shit's crazy like no who's
doing that you know what i mean and like
snapdog's not signed to ysl like he's
just someone who was around you know
like not a lot of people are that
generous
or thoughtful especially in the music
industry
most of these fools is fake as [ __ ] it's
a [ __ ] they'll let you hang out
because they're there's something that's
beneficial to them yeah when you're
hanging around
second that [ __ ] goes away
but it's funny i said that [ __ ] in the
interview i said one of the most solid
[ __ ] the most solid [ __ ] next to nick
that i met in this [ __ ] was long
wow i said that that says a lot man ago
because he's just a real [ __ ] bro like
so 100 and it's like it's like it feel
like family he treats you like your
family if he [ __ ] with you [ __ ] with you
all the way i swear